bonsoir la pandémie de kobe de 19
poursuit sa progression mondiale 2,1
millions de personnes sont atteintes du
coc vie de dix neuf cent quarante mille
ans sont décédés mais plus de 500 29000
sont guéris les etats unis sont le pays
le plus touché au monde avec 641 milka
et 31 mille décès l'europe reste
fortement impacté avec un million de cas
et plus de 97 milles morts
l'espagne enregistrent 180 1983 mille
cas et plus de 19000 décès en italie
l'épidémie est à l'origine de 165000 cas
et près de 22000 décès ce soir en france
nous des comptes ont un total de 108
1847 cas confirmés selon santé publique
france soit 2641 cas de plus qui hier
depuis le début de l'épidémie
ce sont 110 mille passages aux urgences
pour suspicion de covile 19 qui ont été
enregistrés et plus de soixante quinze
mille huit cent cinquante personnes
atteintes par la maladie qui ont dû être
hospitalisés c'est totalement inédit
les remontées de 1250 établissements de
santé font état de 31 mille trois cent
cinq personnes encore hospitalisées pour
infection kovy 19 le nombre de malades
hospitalisés reste donc très important
en 24 heures ce sont 1800 23 nouveaux
malades qui sont entrés à l'hôpital mais
le solde présente pour la deuxième fois
une baisse car grâce aux sorties qui
sont nombreuses nous avons 474 personnes
hospitalisées en moins par rapport à
hier c'est à une décroissance est un
indicateur important mais qui
nécessitent d'être confirmée encore dans
les prochains jours nos efforts
collectifs
montrent leur efficacité ce n'est qu'en
respectant scrupuleusement les gestes
barrière le confinement
la distanciation physique d'au moins un
mètre et la distanciation social avec la
réduction des contacts que nous y
parviendrons tous ensemble 6248 patients
nécessitent des soins lourds en
réanimation
un tiers de ces patients ont moins de 60
ans et nous comptons 80 18 patients de
moins de 30 ans en réanimation au cours
des dernières 24 heures 270 nouveaux
patients qu'au vu de 19 ont été admis en
réanimation c'est beaucoup heureusement
le solde reste négatif depuis une
semaine
aujourd'hui il est de 209 patients en
moins d'une légère baisse des besoins
réanimation se confirme mais je vous le
rappelle 6248 patients en réanimation
c'est beaucoup plus que la capacité
maximale initial de la réanimation en
france il existe toujours des tensions
dans certaines régions 67 % des patients
hospitalisés en réanimation ont déjà des
problèmes de santé pré existants et 53%
d'entre eux ont plus de 65 ans dans les
outre mer guadeloupe guyane réunion
martinique mayotte on relève 123
hospitalisations dont 45 en réanimation
depuis le début d'épidémie près de 30 de
1812 personnes hospitalisées sont
rentrés à domicile et c'est sans compter
les dizaines de milliers de personnes
guéries en ville sans passage par
l'hôpital
la circulation du virus se stabilise
donc à un niveau élevé
1800 nouveaux cas hospitalisés 270
nouveaux cas en réanimation
vous savez que nous observons avec
beaucoup d'attention la situation dans
les établissements sociaux et médico
sociaux en particulier les ehpad 5451
établissements sociaux et médico sociaux
participent et déclare des cas et c'est
très important d'avoir cette remontée
d'informations au niveau national ainsi
au total depuis le début de l'épidémie
nous avons cinquante six mille 180 cas
dont 18 1967 confirmée par test et 37
1213 cas possibles de kovy de 10,9 au
sein de ces établissements
l'essentiel des cas sont survenus en
semaine 12 13 et 14
donc plutôt au mois de mars en ce qui
concerne la mortalité
nous avons une première source qui a la
mortalité hospitalière 11060 décès sont
à déplorer depuis le 1er mars 82 % de
ces décès surviennent chez des personnes
de plus de 70 ans et 20 décès ont été
enregistrés
outre-mer nous déplorons par ailleurs
dans les établissements sociaux et
médico-sociaux 6860 décès depuis le
début de l'épidémie soit le 1er mars
l'essentiel de ces décès est observée en
ehpad
depuis le 1er mars en additionnant les
décès à l'hôpital et en établissements
sociaux et médico sociaux
nous déplorons donc dix sept mille neuf
cent vingt décès en france en lien avec
l'épidémie l'insee propose vous le savez
des données concernant l'ensemble des
décès ce qu'on appelle les décès toutes
causes confondues
il ne s'agit donc pas seulement des
décès liés au co vide
nous aurons céder ses données mais après
étude de tous les certificats de décès
mais par contre la part attribuée à
l'ogc nice n'est pas encore connue mais
les comparaisons nous permettent
d'analyser les décès de façon
hebdomadaire et de les comparer d'année
en année
c'est ainsi que nous pouvons parler d'
une sur mortalité toutes causes
confondues par rapport à l'attendu et
par rapport à l'observer année
apprennent l'évolution de la mortalité
toutes causes confondues montre un excès
qui est détecté depuis mi mars à
l'échelon national en particulier
l'excès de décès par rapport à la
mortalité attendue lors d'un mois de
mars poursuit sa hausse progressivement
cet excès était de 16% en semaine 12 de
34 8 % en semaine 13 sur la semaine 14
la semaine où il ya eu énormément
d'hospitalisation ou d'épidémie
frappait très fortement c'est une
semaine du 30 mars au 5 avril
l'excès de décès atteint 58 2%
c'est un niveau d'excès exceptionnel qui
n'avait jamais été atteint en france
depuis l'été 2003 l'excès poursuit sa
hausse sur la semaine 15 et atteint déjà
plus 27% sont des données encore non
consolidées puisque la semaine 15 d'une
semaine très proche du 6 au 12 avril à
l'échelon régional au cours de cette
semaine 15 du 6 au 12 avril
l'excès émergent dans quatre régions
supplémentaires les hauts de france
l'auvergne rhône-alpes au centre val de
loire et normandie et s'ajoute donc aux
trois régions qui étaient déjà en excès
ile-de-france grand test et bourgogne
franche comté à l'échelon départemental
en semaine 15 29 départements présentent
déjà un excès de mortalité ces
départements sont situés en
ile-de-france grand s de bourgogne
franche comté centre val de loire
en ce qui concerne les certificats
électroniques de décès vous savez que la
france bénéficie de cette solution de
certification électronique des décès qui
permet d'avoir des informations
quasiment en temps réel
nous notons que 26,7 pour cent de ces
certificats disponibles soit déjà 6444
déclaration de décès haute tenue et
surtout analyser depuis le 1er mars
contiennent une mention d'infection
coville 19 et concernent majoritairement
les plus de 65 ans l'excellent
mentalités observée en france concerne
d'ailleurs toujours majoritairement des
personnes de plus de 65 ans toutes et
tous nous continuons donc à agir
ensemble contre la pandémie que ce soit
en respectant le confinement en
soutenant les actions de soins nous
sommes tous actifs dans la lutte contre
la diffusion du virus en respectant tous
ensemble les gestes barrières et les
mesures de distanciation physique et
social je vous remercie
question pour diaspora news magazine la
première la vaccination par le bcg
pendant l'enfance pourrait-elle immunisé
contre le coronavirus alors c'est une
question importante vous savez qu'en
france nous vaccinons
largement aimé massivement les français
contre le bcg c'est une vaccination
obligatoire si une action qui est une
vaccination qui reste fortement
recommandé c'est une particularité de la
france donc là encore il faudrait des
études épidémiologiques bien menée pour
savoir s'il ya une différence entre des
personnes qui ont été vaccinées par le
bcg d'autres qui ne l'ont pas été il y à
une étude qui va être menée au niveau
européen pour savoir si la vaccination
bcg qui provoque une réaction
immunitaire importante puisque c'est un
vaccin vivant par une souche vivant tu
peux avoir un impact dans la protection
contre le courant des virus a fait
partie des hypothèses scientifiques qui
sont actuellement testés par des
scientifiques européens
qu'en est il des orages de cytokines
soupçonné d'être responsable de cas
graves de kobe 19 quels sont les
traitements pour les stopper
alors c'est une question très technique
je vais essayer de y apporter une
réponse pour que tout le monde puisse
comprendre en pratique lorsque l'on voit
des des syndromes de détresse
respiratoire aiguë en réanimation il ya
plusieurs causes première cause le
poumon est envahi par le virus ça a été
décrit et donc il ya une réaction du
poumon à l'afflux de virus et une
destruction des cellules qui fait que le
boom on n'arrive plus à assumer son rôle
d'oxygénation du corps deuxième
hypothèse c'est celle que vous avez
cités c'est finalement une réaction
inflammatoire anormal excessive qui
entraîne un oedème pulmonaire c'est à
dire qu'il ya un afflux de liquide dans
les poumons et ce qui entraîne la
difficulté respiratoire majeur et la
nécessité de vente y aider le patient
troisième hypothèse notamment émises par
les italiens une hypothèse de deux
micros trombi de micro blocage de
caillots dans l'est dans les capillaires
pulmonaire qui ferait aussi participé à
cette détresse respiratoire d'envoyer
qu'il ya beaucoup de mécanismes tous les
réanimateurs au monde travaille sur les
explications sous jacente à 7 à cette
anomalie respiratoires et il ya donc des
essais qui sont menées vous savez que
les essais sont menés en france en
particulier avec des immunomodulateurs
et dès les essais sont en cours
il y aura même des réponses
intermédiaire dans les prochains jours
il ya aussi des essais avec le plasma de
convalescents donc utiliser des
anticorps de personnes guéries pour
traiter des cas graves
il ya aussi des essais avec des cellules
souches
donc entre les anti-inflammatoires
particuliers notamment la place des
corticoïdes en réanimation
entre les immuno modulateurs les
cellules souches
le plasma convalescente toutes sortes de
d'attitude thérapeutiques sont
actuellement testés pour proposer les
meilleurs soins aux patients les plus
graves de questions pour l' agence de
presse italienne ansa
est il correct de comparer les données
sur la mortalité dans les différents
pays compte tenu que la france inclus
les décès en ehpad et donc même des cas
considéré possible qu vider pas testé
alors c'est toute la difficulté des
comparaisons internationales d'abord
vous le savez la démographie n'est pas
la même dans les pays et les zones
touchées ne sont pas les mêmes il ya des
zones qui ont plus de sujets jeunes et
des zones qui ont dès qu'ils ont des
sujets plus âgés
c'est le cas aussi en france au sein du
territoire national département de
mayotte par exemple est un département
très jeune d'autres départements du sud
de la france ont une population plus
âgée donc là encore la démographie
compte le recensement aussi content nous
avons décidé de recenser la mortalité de
façon très exhaustive avec un recueil de
données que je vous donne tous les soirs
sur la mortalité enregistrée en milieu
hospitalier
nous avons aussi maintenant cette source
de remonter des ehpad et des
établissements de santé et de soins
médicaux sociaux qui nous donne les
décès observés en établissement là
encore ce sera très compliqué de savoir
si oui ou non la mortalité attribuable
aux coronavirus est donc là encore nous
nous avons effectivement ces cas
possibles mais que nous comptons et
peut-être de que d'autres pays ne le
font pas et puis vous avez cette
surveillance par l'insee par l'inserm de
la mortalité toutes causes où nous
aurons d'abord cet excès de mortalité
observée et où ensuite nous aurons
l'analyse des causes de décès avec la
mention dans les certificats
électroniques ou dans les certificats
classique de l'infection à covit donc
ces données seront consolidées au fur et
à mesure elles seront d'ailleurs comparé
au niveau international et au niveau
européen car la france participe à un
réseau européen de surveillance de la
mortalité tous les pays européens y
participent et donc nous aurons dans
quelques semaines et probablement plus
tôt dans quelques mois la possibilité de
comparer l'impact de l'infection et de
l'épidémie en terme de mortalité les
autres pays utilise la même méthode
depuis le début
la france rattrape tel en retard non la
france ne rattrape pas un retard le seul
le retard qu'on aurait pu avoir cédé
retard de déclaration lors des épisodes
comme des week-ends donc c'est pour ça
que je vous donnais avec un peu de
prudence les chiffres après le long
week-end de que nous venons de traverser
mais sinon tous les établissements
déclarer l'éclair de façon très
performante nous avons même les deux
semaines de déclarations
donc je crois que chaque pays essaie de
mettre en place un dispositif performant
c'est le cas de nos voisins c'est le cas
de la grande-bretagne c'est le cas de
l'allemagne c'est le cas de l'espagne je
pense que nous avons des situations
assez comparable en termes de capacité à
détecter les délais décès et à aller
compter comme je voulais expliquer
notamment grâce à ce réseau européen
question pour hospimedia le groupe accor
a annoncé la mobilisation en
ile-de-france de certains de ses hôtels
pour accueillir des patients qu'aux
vives 19 ans sortie d'hospitalisation
combien d'hôtels sont concernés qui
paiera la facture l'hôpital où l'état
qu'en est il dans les autres régions je
n'ai pas d'informations sur cette
mobilisation vrai de se retourner vers
le back up on savoir quel est son plan
de mobilisation et qu'est ce qu'il
souhaite proposer à l'époque trois
questions pour la paix m
quel est le taux de mortalité globale en
réanimation chez les patients covit 19
alors c'est une question que je
souhaiterais traité avec beaucoup de
précaution parce que d'abord beaucoup de
patients sont en réanimation beaucoup de
familles sont extrêmement inquiète de ce
soir parce qu'elles ont un proche en
réanimation
donc premièrement quand on est en
réanimation sait qu'on a une détresse
vitale au moins sur un organe est ce le
cas en général sur cette difficulté
respiratoire qui nécessitent souvent une
ventilation artificielle
il ya de très grandes différences dans
la survie des patients en réanimation
je vous donne quelques exemples selon
que l'on est jeunes sans pathologie ce
sans pathologie chronique sous-jacente
avec un bon pronostic parce que la
détresse respiratoire est modéré par ce
que vous répondez bien à la respiration
à la ventilation mécanique
le pronostic est bon quand on a un
patient qui a déjà beaucoup de
pathologique et fragile qui est muni des
prix mais qui a un poumon abîmé déjà par
une maladie respiratoire qui est âgée le
pronostic est beaucoup plus sévère et
donc il est très difficile de donner un
pronostic moyen taux dépend d'eux
le tarif du patient les premiers
résultats que nous avons sur les données
de santé publique france qui vont être
publiés montrent bien qu'il ya des
grandes variations dans la survie du
patient liée à l'âge lié à la pathologie
sous jacente est surtout liée à la
sévérité de votre état quand vous êtes
pris en charge en réanimation
l'om est dit que pour sortir du
confinement il faut notamment que les
systèmes sanitaires soient prêts à
détecter tester isolés et traités tous
les cas de kobe 19 et tracer chaque
chaque contact sera ton prêt en france
le 11 mai alors c'est l'objectif qui est
fixé par le président la république
c'est ce que nous allons faire tous
ensemble parce qu'effectivement
l'objectif du confinement et
l'efficacité du confinement les français
le constate tous les soirs commence à
être démontrée donc il faut absolument
poursuivre nos efforts pour que nous non
seulement nous nous soulageons nos
équipes soignantes nous soulageons le
talent mais surtout que nous soyons avec
une diffusion du virus beaucoup moins
importante au moment du des confirmands
justement pour pouvoir appliquer cette
stratégie qui comme vous le voyez très
ambitieuse qui est d'être capable de
détecter très vite une personne
symptomatique de pouvoir la tester très
vite sur tout le territoire national
d'isoler de façon efficace la personne
malade de repérer très vite aussi toutes
les personnes avec lesquelles elle a été
en contact et de pouvoir la proposer ce
qu'on appelle un contact racing de
pouvoir les informer immédiatement et la
proposer une conduite à tenir donc testé
pour tester n'a pas de sens mais testé
pour isoler et pour informer les cas
contacts a du sens c'est un peu ce que
nous avons vécu rappelez-vous au début
de l'épidémie lorsque nous cherchons
tous les contacts des cas quelle est
votre réaction aux critiques de
l'administration 30 mais aussi de jean
yves le drian sur l'action de l' oms au
début de la crise pas de réaction
question pour la paix sur la base d'
analyse des données sanitaires
l'institut irsn a conclu que l'épidémie
a atteint son pic en france la semaine
dernière
confirmez vous cette analyse et
serait-il possible de sortir du
confinement à partir du 11 mai éviter un
nouveau pic si la france n'a toujours
pas la capacité de faire les tests en
masse à cette date alors sur l'évolution
épidémiologique je vous ai montré hier
des graves qui montre vraiment qu'on est
plus face à un plateau qu'à un pic à un
pic de l'art d'être très aigu on a passé
le cap et tout dégringole c'est
malheureusement pas la situation on est
vraiment sur quelque chose
est lent mais qui va dans le bon sens et
c'est une bonne nouvelle par contre que
je ce que j'essaie de passer comme idée
vraiment c'est important c'est que il
reste encore une situation totalement
anormale vous ai dit et plus de 6000
patients en réanimation le maximum de la
réanimation en france en janvier et tous
les ans et 5 c'est 5000 donc on est
vraiment dans une situation totalement
exceptionnel l'épidémie reste très
dynamique je vous ai donné le nombre de
patients qui arrivent à l'hôpital tous
lés jours 1800 c'est quand même
considérable et les centaines de
patients qui arrivent en réanimation
donc les patients qui arrivent à
l'hôpital sont très nombreux les
patients qui arrivent en réanimation
reste très nombreux nous sommes entre
guillemets soutenu par un nombre
important de sortie tant mieux mais
l'activité hospitalière est anormale et
le nombre de lits de réanimation reste
très élevé donc on est plutôt sur un
plateau qui évolue doucement vers une
décroissance tant mieux mais ce n'est
pas la chute observée parfois après des
pics épidémiques avec une dégringolade
rapide du nombre de cas malheureusement
on n'est pas devant cette situation de
pique on est plutôt devant une situation
de plateau lentement des croissants et
c'est une bonne nouvelle mais
malheureusement la cinétique n'est pas à
celle qui est sous-entendu par le terme
pick 3 questions pour mehdi sites en
france et dans le monde le principe de
précaution est appliqué pour toutes les
personnes en contact avec les corps des
victimes du soignant aux pompes funèbres
quelles recommandations pour l'entourage
en cas de décès à domicile alors ce sont
les mêmes recommandations qu avant le
décès c'est à dire qu'en pratique vous
savez que des personnes qui ont aperçu
une personne malade à domicile doivent
faire très attention doivent les halls
et doivent être protégés lorsque elles
sont en contact avec cette personne
c'est tous les enjeux d'ailleurs du
confinement à domicile c'est d'être
capable de mettre ce double confinement
le confinement du foyer et le
confinement du malade et donc il ya
effectivement des tout simplement les
mesures barrières à appliquer au moment
du décès rien de plus rien de moins et
donc cessons les gestes barrière qui
sont toujours les plus efficaces l'ordre
des médecins s'est dit défavorable à la
réouverture des écoles le 11 mai le
déconfinement progressif sera-t-il
compromis c'est l'avis de l'ordre des
médecins il n'est pas faire de
commentaires sur la vie de l'ordre des
médecins
l'épidémie est plus présent dans
certaines régions le onze maires
déconfinement progressive par zone
géographique et géographique pardon et
il envisage
et si oui quelles seraient les régions d
confiné en premier alors c'est une bonne
question le gouvernement y travaillent
évidemment ce que le président
république a bien indiqué de façon très
claire dans son discours c'est qu'il
tiendrait compte de la situation
épidémiologique au moment du confinement
du déconfinement donc nous allons
observer avec beaucoup d'attention
l'évolution de la situation dans les
régions ce que les français ont bien
compris c'est que les régions n'ont pas
était de toucher du tout de la même
façon
notamment dans un grand quart nord-est
il ya des régions qui ont été presque
épargné en tout cas qui ont été beaucoup
moins touché durement que les autres
donc là encore on sera très attentifs à
l'évolution entre maintenant et le 11
mai et puis surtout d'être capable aussi
d'être très réactif à l'évolution de la
situation
après le 11 mai de questions pour france
2 pour l'émission envoyé spécial
selon vous le bilan en france serait-il
moins lourd si 20 millions de votants ne
s'étaient pas rendus aux urnes le 20
mars dernier
alors c'est impossible de répondre à
cette question ce d'autant que la vraie
question est que s'est il passé avant la
mise en place du confinement et que
s'est-il passé après la mise en place du
confinement mais avec le confinement a
été mis en place très rapidement un
mardi à midi et donc il ya eu une
activité normale jusqu'à ce mardi à midi
il ya eu des déplacements il ya eu des
réunions et donc l'objectif du
confinement par contre était de réduire
les contacts et cet objectif il est
vraiment rempli dans le sens où
aujourd'hui il faut que les français se
rendent compte que malgré l'importance
de l'épidémie que malgré le nombre de
malades hospitalisés le nombre de
malades en réa et le nombre très
important de décès que nous observons
nous aurions eu un bilan beaucoup plus
lourd si le confinement n'avait pas été
solidairement et collectivement
appliquée par les français
le maintien du premier tour des
municipales était-il d'un point de vue
strictement sanitaire une erreur je sais
la même réponse est à dire qu en
pratique ce qu'il fait ce qu'il faudrait
analyser c'est de savoir si les contacts
avant la mise en place du confinement
ont été à l'origine de beaucoup de cas
c'est très dur c'est de l'analyser et
donc ce n'est pas spécialement
l'organisation de delà du premier tour
qui pose problème c'est simplement tous
les contacts qui ont eu lieu avant la
mise en place du confinement et après on
voit bien que le nombre de contacts a
beaucoup diminué mais les français n'ont
vécu normalement jusqu'à la mise en
place du confinement de questions pour
l'usiné
elle vous avait parlé de qualification
de tests sérologiques quand le résultat
de ces qualifications sera disponible et
quand est ce qu une liste de tests
sérologiques approuvé disponible en
france sera publié
alors je voudrais d'abord rappeler la
différence très importante entre les
tests virologiques et les tests
sérologiques c'est important que les
français le comprennent parce que il ya
une espèce de confusion dans ces tests
les tests virologiques sont très
importants et il faut qu'on en est en
nombre parce que ce sont des tests qui
permettent de dire si le malade qui a
les symptômes cas mal à la gorge qui a
de la fièvre a ou non le virus est là le
président a été très clair nous devons
offrir une capacité de test pour toute
personne malade ou qu'elle soit sur le
territoire national et qu'elle est axée
dans la journée à ce test qui lui dit si
oui ou non elle est infecté les tests
sérologiques ont une portée toute assez
différentes
ils sont après l'infection à distance de
l'affection pour savoir si oui ou non on
a développé des anticorps si oui ou non
on a une immunité contre virus donc ce
n'est plus du tout un test d'urgence
c'est d'ailleurs un test qui nécessitera
de de discuter de son indication pour
plusieurs raisons d'abord parce que
comme vous le savez la plupart des pays
européens commencent à donner des
résultats et les français son dossier en
train de retour de donner des résultats
certains sont déjà publiées sur le fait
que l'immunité collective est encore
très basses que très peu de français ont
rencontré le virus probablement beaucoup
moins que de dire que 10% et ça dépend
encore des régions vous allez on a eu
des réponses de l'inserm sur la région
ile de france donc on voit bien que
l'immunité collective n'est pas atteinte
et que probablement une grande majorité
français n'ont pas d'anticorps donc
apprenez ce premier constat est donc une
une indication de tests qui a peu
d'importance justement du fait de cette
faible prévalence
par ailleurs si on veut faire ce test il
faut le faire à distance vraiment une
forte une forte d'un ford délai par
rapport à l'infection au moins deux à
trois semaines après l'infection est la
vraie question ensuite c'est qu'est-ce
qu'on fait du test qu'est-ce qu'on fait
du résultat
que signifie d'avoir des anticorps ou
pas d'anticorps n'envoyer que ça fait
beaucoup de questions donc aujourd'hui
nous avons évidemment mobilisé nos
experts
la haute autorité de santé vient de
sortir aujourd'hui les recommandations
de son collège
sur le cahier des charges que doit
remplir un laboratoire qui voudraient
mettre à disposition des sérologies il y
aura des sérologies classiques qui sont
en fait après une prise de sang en
laboratoire il y aura sans doute des
sérologies qui se passe par des tests
rapides mais là encore après le passage
par la haute autorité de santé
la rsm et la validation de la qualité de
ces tests par le centre national de
référence la vraie question sera la
place de ces tests sérologiques dans
l'arsenal de des tests français est le
vrai test principal que les français
doivent retenir pour les prochaines
semaines c'est le tests virologiques qui
leur dit si oui ou non ils sont malades
ou en étant sur les produits
anesthésiants y at il encore des
tensions aux pénuries
il ya des tensions partout sur les
produits d'anesthésié et de réanimation
dans l'ensemble du monde du fait de
l'augmentation des besoins liés au
nombre de patients en réanimation mais
nous sommes très concentrés très
mobilisée pour qu'il n'y ait pas de
rupture et de pénurie donc c'est un
effort interne en france entre les
réanimations et les blocs opératoires
c'est un effort européen et nous sommes
vraiment très attentif à ce que aucun
malade n'est un problème d'accès à ce
type de produits c'est la dernière
question j'en remercie beaucoup